provisoirement situé dans les locaux de
l'hôpital de plaisir le temps de la
construction d'une maison de santé tout
neuf sur le terrain voisin la ruche a
ouvert ses portes en février et
accueille déjà quatre praticiens
paramédicaux est très important ici à
plaisir c'est d'avoir à dos et la maison
de santé à l'hôpital de plaisir c'est
donc de permettre à toutes les personnes
qui sont malades d'avoir un trait
d'union entre l'hôpital et la ville
à peine ouverte la maison
pluridisciplinaire de santé a dû fermer
pendant le confinement
les praticiens commence donc doucement à
prendre leurs marques et se montre
motivé par ce projet la difficulté en
libéral c'est d'être isolé et d'être
seul donc l'intérêt d'être dans une
équipe pluridisciplinaire ces deux
d'échanger avec des collègues de créer
des projets 6-4 paramédicaux se sont
déjà installés le plus difficile reste
de trouver les médecins généralistes qui
intégreront la maison de santé
définitive cette infirmière libérale
originaire de plaisir est de la ville à
convaincre de jeunes médecins de
s'installer dans la commune pour qu'on
en a un qui est sûr d'intégrer la maison
de santé définitive donc début 2023 nous
l'espérons et non c'est presque fait
mais nous en cherchons deux autres donc
je continue avec mes collègues à séduire
à parler de notre maison de santé parmi
les objectifs de la ruche pouvoir
proposer des créneaux d'urgence sans
rendez vous le bâtiment de 600 mètres
carrés financé par le département
devraient être livrés d'ici 2023
la ville de plaisir en assurera la
gestion